If you were trapped 13,000 meters below
the Earth's surface, what would you do?
You'll have to give up everything you love
in order to reach the bottom, to find answers.
And there's no turning back.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do and how to beat
Bondrewd of the novel in Made an Abyss.
Dawn of the Deep Soul.
These kids have no idea
that they will soon have to give up everything
they love in order to make their dreams come true.
And they have no clue of what
it will cost them in the process.
Riko and Reg,
after going through so much in the abyss,
have finally teamed up with this
fur ball named Nanachi,
and they are off continuing their adventure
to find answers to their most desperate questions
down within the abyss. Like,
where the hell is Riko's mother?
Who wrote that note
that Riko found telling her to come down here?
And what in the hell is Reg
and where in the abyss did he come from?
This is what the group hopes to find out.
And they have nearly reached the fifth layer
of this horrifying abyss.
And they come across the garden
of the Flowers of Fortitude.
And it is here where they hear the most horrifying
sounds, unknown, echoing screams
coming across from the distance.
And just then finally, spots a cave raider.
But as Reg goes to take a closer look, Nanette,
she realizes that this cave
raider is, in fact,
a member of the terrifying Umbra Hands.
Okay, this is insane.
These guys have already crossed through
what is basically literally hell itself.
And Riko has already almost died.
And this time they also had to Nanachi,
who might as well be
the residents of the abyss down here,
since she practically knows this place
like the back of her paw, she should have
but failed to inform the gang of the dangers
of this seemingly beautiful garden,
because even though this place looks magical,
there's more to it than meets the eye.
This wonderous garden is classified
as especially dangerous because of the migration
of the Amaranth interceptors, which,
by the way, are insects that live within the fifth
to six layer of the abyss and regularly use
the cover of this expansive garden
to blend in with the leaves, hence
the name deceptor.
Because these bastards
will turn this garden into a death trap
against anyone who gets too close to them.
They attack humans and plant
living larva inside their flesh.
Nanachi should have prevented Reg from closing
the gap between them and that Umbra Hands member
by spending more time
doing reconnaissance from afar
since they already have the tech to spy
from a distance.
If they had simply waited a moment longer,
Nanachi could have figured out who this guy was
before Reg got spotted.
Because the Umbra hands are members of Bondrewd's
group of cave raiders
who might as well be called his minions
because they'll do anything for Bondrewd himself,
which means this group
needs to take more precautions
the further down they go within the abyss,
because it won't always be nature itself.
That they only have to look out for.
It is at this moment that now Nanachi realizes
just who the hell this horrifying cave raider is
and where he came from. But it's too late.
Because this dude has just locked
eyes with our dear old Reg, making his arm hairs
stand to attention and fear.
Suddenly the cave raider disappears
and basically teleport right in front of Reg,
prompting him to raise his weaponized arm
in defense.
Reg now more on guard than he's ever been.
Asks if that scream he heard was his doing
but the cave raider simply warns Reg to pipe down
or he'll wake them.
This menacing cave raider
with a voice deeper than Darth Vader then hands
Reg an old relic that they lost back in Season
one, Riko's Blaze reap relic,
which is a highly destructive, large pickax
that contains everlasting gunpowder that functions
as basically a mini rocket launcher.
The Cave Raider then informs
Reg that this area is off limits and that they've
all been under watch for some time now.
Shocking Nanachi and proving that
who awaits them down within
the abyss is far more powerful
than they could ever imagine.
Nanachi warns Reg to back off.
But Reg is too determined to find out
more about this guy, who then demands to know
just what this Cave Raider was up to.
Just then,
Riko takes out a pamphlet containing information
on just what it is that Reg is about to see
and it is truly horrifying.
Reg then comes across this insect
hiding within the leaves all around him
in this beautiful garden where they attack
and implanted their larva inside organisms
that come near them, just like this guy.
They keep their victims just alive enough
so that they can continue
to consume on their flesh for even longer
showing us the horrors of what awaits this group
the further down they descend.
And this is just the tip of the iceberg.
It is
then when they all hear a siren in the distance
marking it as a signal for this Ambre Hand
Cave Raider to get out his flamethrower
and to begin burning the entirety of the field
while Reg looks on in shock
as the two other insect infested
cave raiders burn along with the flower field.
Right then the cave raider mentions that
the sovereign of Dawn is eagerly awaiting them all
just then, Nancy tells Reg
to get the hell out of there, and Reg rushes
back to the group and they decide to push forward,
going deeper down within the abyss.
Later,
the group finally reaches the final frontier,
the fifth layer, also known as the Sea of Corpses,
the last point within the abyss
that humans can return from
because once they cross this layer,
once they go past this point,
they can never return to the surface.
And the group comes across a forward
operating base in the distance,
one that is bound roots personal research lab.
And it is also the base where Nanachi
was experimented on, known as Ido Front,
which also functions as a base that holds
the only entrance to the sixth layer,
as it is also a place where expert white
whistle explorers use for their last descent.
Not achieved then says that in order for them
to get to the sixth layer, they'll likely come
across Bondrewd himself, who is a psychopathic,
legendary, all powerful mad scientist
who's willing to sacrifice anything
in order to find out the secrets of the abyss.
The group then readies to enter
into what will be their final test.
Okay, hold up here.
These guys are approaching this way too casually.
This is Ido Front, the final obstacle in their way
to going further down into the abyss.
And this space is also where the terrifying
Bondrewd the novel lives and works in.
This guy is a legendary white whistle explorer,
and the guy who owns and warned us back in season
one that this guy, according to everyone up
on the surface, regularly resorts to illegal
and morally questionable means in order
to get his way as this station's top scientist.
Seriously, this guy will do whatever it takes
if it means him becoming one step closer
to discovering the secrets
of the abyss and Nanachi herself is proof
that he's experimented on humans
before turning them into actual monsters
in pursuit of science.
And this is the last stop before they likely
come face to face with this monster.
So if I was them, I'd
take a day to talk things over,
because if they really want to follow
through with this, they better plan this out.
Because Bondrewd has been known
to steal relics in the past and also has a history
of stealing artifacts to further his own gain.
And he's a man of knowledge.
So, like, what do you think he'll do once
he finds out that Rogue is basically a walking,
living, breathing relic of the abyss?
I'm pretty darn
sure he's not going to let him walk out of there.
Reg is singularly unique.
So far, we've only found him
as the only relic that is sentient. Reg.
His body could contain a myriad of secrets
that Bondrewd would love to exploit.
If he's curious enough about him,
I would look into seeing
if we could get some maps of this place,
if maybe we could go halfway around,
if there was any way
we could go under it,
because I'm pretty sure we would all prefer
to not get caught by a mad scientist.
But if we insisted on going through it,
I would make sure that we armed ourselves
to the teeth with whatever
makeshift weaponry we could find,
because we're going to need all the strength
we can muster once we step foot inside
that sinister looking base
and we need to keep our guard way up.
The group begins to make plans
on how to infiltrate the menacing base,
and they make note of the fact
that this place was built on
the ruins of what was once a ruined site
thousands of years ago.
Little do they realize
that they're being watched by someone
and this someone will change their lives forever.
The group then reaches an impasse
as actually warns them of what's to come
and how they should choose their words carefully
because they don't know how much Bondrewd
and his goons know information is power
and warns them that whatever happens to them,
they shouldn't show any fear.
And oh, how right little Nanette
she is. The gang then reaches a cold,
dark entrance way,
and they are greeted by none other
than the little being
that will change their lives.
This little girl,
who we come to find is named Houska
as her beady eyes and hunger for curiosity,
countered the group with a barrage of questions.
A million miles a minute, but Reg's mouth
remain sealed as he remembers not a cheese warning
to not give too much away.
It is then here that precious words
usher in a wave of terror for the group,
as she calls out the words papa
to a dreaded strange figure approaching
in the distance and one that sends shivers down
Nanachi his spine.
They are now face to face with the infamous
Bondrewd, the novel The Sovereign of Don.
In a shocking twist, Bondrewd greets
the group cheerfully and congratulates
Nanachi on being set free, alluding to
what happened to her dear old cursed friend
who Reg set free days back
by putting her out of her misery.
Traumatized Nanachi, opts to skip the pleasantries
and gets to the main point of why they're here.
They want to descend through the entrance
into the sixth layer of the abyss.
But Bondrewd informs them that the entrance
to the sixth layer can only be opened by the sound
of a white whistle, and only the true owner
of that white whistle can activate the doorway
as the timbre of its sound frequency must match
perfectly with that of the original owner.
This means that Riko's group
can't continue their journey, since Riko
only has her mother's white whistle and lacks
one of her very own.
Okay.
White
whistles are second grade artifacts and are ones
that are awarded to only the best cave raiders,
though I would not include Bondrewd.
However,
there's only a handful of them in existence.
And if we remember, technically, Riko
never got her own white whistle and was given
her mother's way back
in the beginning. Of Season one.
The timbre that a white whistle gives off
means the sound quality or the tone
quality of a note played on a musical instrument.
Because even within the same family,
different instruments have varying tone timbres.
This is important because this basically means
that you could have two of the same instruments
emitting the same identical pitch
at identical volumes and they'd still produce
distinct timbres or sound colors between the two.
And despite being blood related,
I doubt Riko can perfectly 100%
match the sound of her mother
that she made on the white whistle.
Now, there's
still a ton that we don't know about the abyss
and Bondrewd's and outright filthy scumbag.
But I take a shot in the dark
and ask if Bondrewd himself
could open up the portal to the sixth layer
using his white whistle.
Worst case, he says no, or makes up some excuse
as to why he can't do it.
And this way we can simply head our way back
out of this creepy base and call it a day.
Because I know that this dead space wearing Dr.
Isaac wannabe
scientist has got some tricks up his sleeve,
and I do not want to wait around
to find out what those are.
Riko is devastated at the news
as she clutches onto her mother's white whistle,
and she remembers that this is the same thing
that beard guy and Ozen mentioned before.
Riko's naive young nature proves once again
that life simply won't work out
because you had good intentions and little
does she realize that her misery is
only going to get worse as her beloved
friends will die because of her soon enough?
Bondrewd then offers them a place
to stay at this base and mentions
that Prushka already made a room for them.
And so with little choice and needing
time to think on their next move,
the group cautiously accepts his invitation,
entering further into the eerie compound
full of fanatical white whistles
who will do anything to further
their own knowledge of the barely explored abyss?
Prushka then leads the group down the faded
orange hallways, showing them
the ins and outs, the station
and more importantly, what's on and off limits
to them opening the own door to a barren room
full of meal rations.
Here we also find out more information on Prushka
about how she was born down here and how she has
never been to the surface, nor has he ever seen
the glory of what a true dawn looks like.
Although while Riko plays nice with Prushka
Nanachi doesn't trust her for shit and wonders
what tricks Bondrewd has up his sleeve this time
around and the group prepares to head for bed.
But before they pass out,
Reg notices something discomforting
and a little strange as he puts on his helmet.
The light that usually comes on
has become fainter this time around,
and to Nanachi having a relic similar to Reg's
helmet suspects that his helmet is showing
the number of uses
he has left before it is empty or unusable.
This shocks Reg, who thinks that this fading
indicator of light on his helmet could mean that
soon Reg will run out of power since he is,
after all, a robot boy who relies on energy.
This means that Reg will need to be careful
and conserve his power, especially with
how he uses his hand incinerator weapon.
And to Nanachi,
he thinks that based on how his power reserve
looks like now, that he may only have
three shots left on his incinerator weapon
before he runs out of power for good.
Later on, Reg and Nanachi eventually head to bed
until later in the night, Riko wakes up
having to use the bathroom only to realize
the bed is empty, confused and alert.
Riko then heads out to find her friends
and also a bathroom, only to come to find a bunch
of locked doors.
And this dark hole
and her bladder lets her know that it needs to go.
Okay, this is too suspicious.
One minute Bondrewd is welcoming us open arms
and already having a bed made up for everybody.
How nice.
And the next minute,
everybody I know is conveniently missing.
There's no way I would go back to bed
in this instance.
And Riko needs to assume
that the worst of the worst has happened.
Because, like I mentioned, we can't trust Bond.
Rude for shit, especially not after
what goes in from back in season one told us.
This guy values knowledge above all else,
which means I wouldn't be surprised
if he was holding all of my friends hostage
right about now at the bottom of some crazy lab
liquified in a petri dish.
Look, the only thing that we can do realistically
speaking is to find out where Rega is
and get the hell out of here.
Because if we can find Reg, then at least
we'll have a shot of being able to help Nanachi
to wherever she is. But in this situation,
we don't have the upper hand.
We're in band roots
place. We're surrounded by his people.
We need to remain calm
and make it our mission to find Prushka,
because she'll likely have a better idea
of where everything is.
And she is naive enough to help us out
without thinking too much about our motives.
I would make sure Prushka leads us
to some weaponry and then go towards finding Reg
because honestly, it makes no sense
for us to venture even into the sixth layer
if we don't have Reg or not techy with us
because one Reg is our best offense
against the abyss and inanity is our best way
in navigating that place safely.
So if we can't find either one of them,
there's little points in staying down here.
The adventure is over.
We need to go back home.
Suddenly, something catches Riko's eyes
as her focus from feeling the gaping
pains of a filled bladder shifts
to a much more enticing object.
The forbidden staircase that Proust previously
mentioned was off limits, thinking
her friends could be up there.
Riko begins making her way upwards,
and suddenly the wonders of the abyss
begin to work their sadistic charm over her,
causing her to lose.
All of a sudden, her sense of direction as OP is
no longer up and down is a plain unknown to her.
And suddenly Riko then collapses while her ears
begin to hear the faint words of someone familiar.
It's Prushka, right?
As she hovers over an injured Riko
politely scolding her for her decisions,
and she mentions that the fifth layer curse
takes away a person's sense of touch and balance,
and this explains what Riko felt.
However, Riko mentions
that all the doors are locked,
which forces Prushka to check them all out.
And she's right.
And Prushka mentions that this has never happened
before.
Little
do they both realize that there is a sinister
reasoning behind this, that they'll soon come
to find out in the most horrible ways.
Meanwhile, as the large hallways of this base
continue to echo an ever present sinister hum,
neo-Nazi decides to hold a secret meeting with her
former boss and captor nodded.
She begins to question who Prushka is to band rude
and he tells her that she was a failed lab
experiment, which he took into race as his own,
which means that Prushka thinks Bondrewd
is the best father in the whole wide world,
and she loves him with all of her heart.
This is why Bondrewd two tells Nanachi
that his research here is finally coming to an end
and that he wants not a cheat
to come back to work for him again.
And so, Nanachi agrees.
Under the condition
that Bondrewd to lets her friends, Reg
and Riko, continue their journey down
towards the sixth layer of the abyss.
But it is at this moment
that Bondrewd realizes that he messed up
because he's already done something bad.
Shocking, Nanachi.
And she runs with all her might to go save Reg.
Reg's eye snap open and he finds himself
strapped down and surrounded by muttering.
Scientists Reg fidgets and begs for his life
as these monsters then chop off his arm,
cutting through mimics to bone and ligaments,
and Reg begins to cry out in pain.
Suddenly Nanachi comes charging and swiping her
paws at these bastard of scientists away from Reg.
And she helps him escape
as she catches up with Riko and Prushka,
who also finds out that this was all organized
on behalf of Prushka Daddy.
The gang then prompts Prushka
to get the hell out of there
as she leads them to a boat before
sending them off.
But unlucky for them, Bondrewd is also a ruthless
and skilled hunter and tracker,
and he follows them all the way down to this cave
right before Reg, then fires up his arm grappling
hook and ascends the duel upward just as this
gigantic stinger head pops up to devour.
All of these scientists hope.
Okay, now, by the looks of things, it seems as
though that they have Bondrewd dead to rights.
But here's the thing.
This gigantic beast is known as a stinger head,
which is a huge, seven tailed scorpion predator
that lurks around the fifth layer
containing enough deadly poison that it can melt
flesh and bone with one sting.
And this creature is not edible at all.
So there's little reason to engage them in battle
unless you think you can actually win
against them.
But a key signal that will let people know
that they are nearby is that a stinger heads nest
has a particular smell that the nest emits
and its somewhat similar to dry to vomit.
Listen, this fact is important because it means
that an experienced cave raider such as Bondrewd
should have been able to recognize the smell
from when he first got there.
And since this creature is not edible,
there's nothing to be gained from bond due
to finding this thing unless he thinks he can win.
Which, if he's right, means we are so screwed
and not out of the woods at all.
I would have taken this opportunity to attack
Bondrewd while he was distracted
and use Regs incinerate a blast to take him out
if we remember, Reg still has about three
uses left before he runs out of energy.
And I think this is one instance
where we would warrant the use of his abilities.
Worst case, if he runs out of juice, we could just
leave him down there and let Bondrewd have it.
Another option.
We'd leave him down there
and eventually come back with our powerful white
whistle friend Ozen,
who we met back in season one.
And we can ask her to help us retrieve Reg.
And with this we would have Ozen and Nanachi,
which means that even if Reg did run out of juice,
we could rely on ozone and Nanachi
to ascend the abyss.
If we did to lose Reg, the gang
then takes refuge behind this sandstone wall
and they contemplate their next move,
hoping that this mighty creature of the abyss
will finally take out Bondrewd.
But they're about to find out
that this mad scientist might as well be the made
in a base version of the Terminator
because he just keeps coming back
and we see Bondrewd pop out seemingly unharmed.
And he comments that he knows where Nanachi is
hiding a trick that Nanachi thinks he's
using to peek in on her sense of sight,
meaning hiding is not an option.
And so the gang decides to switch tactics,
hitting him hard and fast before reinforcements
come charging up to him simultaneously
from all angles.
And in every way that they can
with a Reg coming at him hard and forcing him down
within the cold depths of the frozen water right
above the sixth layer before suddenly
rappelling up backwards,
forcing Bondrewd human body to feel the effects
of what happens when you rapidly ascend the abyss,
which cause him to experience a slew of
biophysical problems that take hold of his body.
And he slowly begins to die
right before Reg drops a final rock on his body.
Just then, reinforcements arrive
along with Prushka, who is absolutely heartbroken
to see her father laying dead in front of her.
And right
then we see the most insane thing ever happen.
This guy, a member of the Umbra, Hans, rips
the helmet off of Bondrewd and places it
upon his head.
All of a sudden,
this umbra had transforms into Bondrewd.
He's alive.
This shocks the whole crew to their core.
And on top of that bond, Druid reveals
something even more sinister.
He congratulates the group on helping push
because love for Bondrewd to grow stronger.
And it means that he can now experiment on Prushka
and use her unrequited love for him
as a means for his body to receive a blessing,
which basically means that now a Bondrewd
will be able to sacrifice Prushka
and used the love that she has towards him
as a means of receiving the blessing of the abyss,
a transformation which will enable his body
to freely roam the depths of the abyss
like Nanachi without dying.
This was his ultimate plan all along,
just like he did with the knowledge and many.
It was made his love for Nanachi
that caused not Nanachi to receive the blessing
and not the curse of the abyss, but it required
sacrifice in the form of Amity losing her soul.
Bondrewd two, then takes his leave
as the distraught gang eventually tries
to figure out how Bond survived and Riko suspects
that he used the Zola
Hulk Soul Slave, a machine relic to copy
his consciousness into another person.
But then not as she thinks
that he can simply transfer his consciousness
even without the mask,
but that he'll have problems
if he expands his forcefield too much
and that the mask is just a symbol.
All the crap balls up.
We've got to talk about what Riko just suggested,
because they went over it way too casually.
We got to talk about the Zola Hulk Soul Slave
Machine Relic for a second, because this is one
such relic that is arguably the most important
relic out there.
Like Riko mentioned, the Zola Hulk allows the user
to basically transplant their mind into other
living beings, spreading the consciousness
of one person through multiple beings.
If I was Riko, I'd say Screw Prushka
and work on finding the Zola Hulk first,
because this way will be able
to outsmart Bondrewd by destroying this relic,
cutting him off from his source of power.
This way, if we try to kill him,
he won't be able to simply jump into another body
and we can finally get rid of him for good.
I know
Prushka is an adorable snot looking mushroom,
but we got to let her
go and get our priorities straight.
If we want to have any shot of defeating Bondrewd.
angry Nanachi and down and out
Riko plot their plans to take back Prushka
and save her Nana.
She already knowing the layout of the base,
lays out the plan for the team.
Reg using his robot
energy absorbing body will head down into the room
that houses the power source for the station.
And while he absorbs
all the energy that this place has to offer,
Riko and Nanachi will buy him some time
by playing nice with Ido front bodyguards.
Meanwhile, a lost and confused to Prushka
finally wakes up naked
and cold on an operating table
and her daddy watches over her
drawing marks all over her body markings
as to where they'll slice her open.
All four Bondrewd's gain,
and he looks into the innocent, pure
eyes of Prushka and mentions
that they'll see the dawn together.
If Riko can get to her in time, she might be
spared and the clock to save her starts ticking.
Elsewhere, Reg reaches the power station room
and not knowing what to do clumsily takes apart
some cord wrapping to unveil some exposed wiring,
and he places his hands on it and absorbs
everything that this station has to offer
and feeling all of this newfound deadly power
coursing throughout his body just then
with the energy drained from the entire station.
Riko and Nanachi use this opportunity to escape
from Bondrewd's guards and this tiny, fluffy,
fat sausage of a creature
leads them right into this sadistic looking lap.
And to Nona, she comes across something
that she should have never stumbled upon used
cartridges filled with crushed spines
and organs of children that Bondrewd used
for all of his sick experiments,
cramming their flesh inside of these cartridges.
And worst of all, Nanachi.
Helped him through all of this.
Any sensory organ that might hamper the curse of
the abyss was chopped off from their body.
All to be used towards Bond.
Ruth's goal of becoming an indestructible cave
raider who can survive all layers
within the abyss.
This is what remains inside those cartridges
and what's not energy
and her friend were subjected to.
And that is what analogy helped a Bondrewd
with as his slave all those years ago.
Nanachi loses it and begins breaking down, crying,
and Riko goes to comfort her,
but they barely have time to get it together.
When incomes Bondrewd himself
Nanachi then angrily accuses Bondrewd
of killing innocent children for his cartridges
as Riko's mouth drops open wide.
But Bond two then mentions that he assumed
they were here to create Riko's White Whistle one
belonging to Riko and not her mother.
And he reveals here
and now to the young group of kids
the realities of what it takes
to actually make a white whistle.
Because in order to make one, someone else
who has undying love towards Riko
must sacrifice themselves in order to create
a white whistle showing just how sadistic one
needs to be in order to become a white
whistle k for radar, Riko's mind is shattered
suddenly not, and she tackles Riko to safety
as a massive explosion erupts in front of bond.
Rude.
It's Reg
and he's powered up and ready to kick ass.
Okay, this is insane, but also a little strange
if what it takes to create a white
whistle is needing
someone else who loves you so much
that they're willing to sacrifice themselves
in order to create a white whistle.
Is this the deep,
dark secret that no one else knows about
or do only the higher levels of the curators know?
I'd imagine that this is something
that would have been brought up at least once.
During her training.
Back in season one, white
whistles are made out of second grade artifacts
called a life reverberating stones,
whereby the raw material needed to help them
make a whistle as Bondrewd said, is a human being.
Basically,
someone needs to be willing to sacrifice
everything for Riko, essentially
killing themselves, and then turning into a life
reverberating stone from which Riko can
then use as her white whistle.
Now, Bondrewd is about to have his hands full
with fighting a related up Reg.
And this means
that this is the perfect opportunity for Riko
and Nani to begin scouring the entire Ido
front base for more Ambre Hand members.
Because remember, from last time
that we killed Bondrewd,
he has the ability to switch his consciousness
with another member of the Umbra.
Hence, this means the Bondrewd is using everyone
working at his base as his slave and back up
a body.
This way,
if his current body dies,
there's still be somebody else around the base
that is willing to offer up their body
to Bondrewd.
So if we take out
all the other members of the Umbra hands,
we might be able to have a shot of stopping
Bondrewd for good and ideally along the way,
find Prushka Regged now powered up
with the energy of the entire base and his body
takes on the sovereign of dawn and Bondrewd
now all powered up
from the energy of dead children in his body,
battles it out with Reg, not energy,
then looks impure as the once sweet little robot
boy she once knew unleashes
his darkest powers upon Bondrewd
tearing him apart and showing him who's boss.
But this sadistic white whistle cave
raider knows his stuff.
And parry his attacks in a series of moves
crushing Reg down flat until Reg begins to let out
a charged, ever expanding release of energy.
Meanwhile, Riko bolts out of there to find proof
just as she comes across the ZOA Hollick artifact.
But all of a sudden, back where Reg is.
Nanachi realizes what he's about to do
and jumps on top of him, begging him not to do
what she thinks he'll do, which is to blow up
the entire base with his most powerful weapon,
his big or incinerator.
But it's too late.
As a gigantic blast is emitted
and much of the base is blown to bits, suddenly
ejecting Nanachi into space when suddenly a back
to normal Reg reawakens and gets her to safety.
Nanachi then lets out a wide eyed grin,
thinking the worst to be over,
but nothing is as it seems in the abyss
because just then a henchman of Bondrewd tackles
Regged down this gaping chasm
right down to the bottom
where we find all of the creatures.
Just like Narnia.
She's once living for rent,
all victims of Bondrewd's, twisted experiments
and suddenly Bondrewd walks into the light.
He's alive as he walks past
all of these creatures.
He utters each and every one of their human names,
indicating that he remembers all who sacrificed
their lives for his efforts, his efforts
into solving the mystery within the abyss.
And he's not happy
with what Reg has done to his base.
And it'll cost him big.
And so the two get ready to battle it out
one final time.
Okay, this is insane.
And they are so screwed
even if Reg could use his most powerful
weapon, his energy beam incinerator,
he's only got a few more shots left in the tank.
But even if he had unlimited
shots on Druid, right now is too fast.
For Regs, who actually hit him.
Now, looking at Bondrewd
in terms of his strengths,
he's pretty much indestructible at the moment.
But the one thing that we can take out
is his cartridges, which again, are specialized
packages made from the flesh of dead children
that he uses to sustain energy and combat
the curse of the abyss. That is his weak point.
Which means if Reg can bridge
the gap between him and Bondrewd,
he could effectively take out
Bondrewd's, cartridges from close range,
either by damaging it through brute force
or through some kind of sustained force.
Of course, this would no doubt require for him
to take some punches as he gets close to it.
But in reality,
this is his best bet to take Bondrewd, out
if Reg doesn't use his energy beam incinerator
at all.
And by judging from how overpowered a Bondrewd is,
we really only have a few options
of taking him down.
Reg battles it out with Bondrewd,
but this time his normal self is no match.
And to make matters worse, Bondrewd begins
transforming
into a creature similar to how knowledge
he was transformed with the love of someone
close to him, sacrificing themselves
for Bond to root for Nanachi.
It was mighty for Bond Road.
It's Prushka and Bondrewd's Body begins to expand
growing claws and a bigger stature,
just as he transforms into his final form,
a creature now able to climb
every inch of the abyss without dying
all hope looks to be lost for all our heroes.
But dReg has not itchy on his side as she,
through the comms, informs Reg of the plan to
take Bondrewd down by evading all of his attacks
and making him use up all of his power cartridges
and Reg weights for his incinerator beam gun
to charge up doing everything that he can.
He dodges all that Bondrewd throws at him
until Bondrewd's, cartridges runs out.
And that's when the gang finds out
that within one of those cartridges is proof Scar.
Why to do an inmate screw it back with another mid
bid review.
So, Albert, tell me,
what did you think of the Made in the Best Movie?
So honestly, the movie is really good.
It builds upon the mystery of the first season,
but it also sets up some questions for season two
like how did this database go?
Or Who became Riko's mother's white whistle?
This sets up a lot of anticipation
for the second season.
What do you think of the movie? Damn.
Well, I'll be honest for me,
I didn't like the movie too much.
You know, the whole point of the TV show
was exploring the abyss and here and explore shit.
Look, I get it. It's more of a character.
PS explained Bond, dude, yadda yadda.
I get it. But exploring the abyss was so exciting
though.
Bondrewd is a badass, however.
All right, back to the video news of Prushka
having been turned into meat mulch shocks
both Reg, Nanachi and even Riko
when the distance crumbles to the floor
in disarray with Regs Old robot arm.
But Reg doesn't have time for her
emotional bullshit as Bondrewd pounces
on a now hapless rogue who fires and misses
his incinerator shot.
All hope seems lost.
But suddenly Riko finally comes to her
senses and launches her big fatty blast with Regs
arm blasting and bruising.
That bastard Bondrewd right in between the bod
as a wave of light glosses over everything
after the light show how she walks up to Bondrewd,
who in his dying state mentions
that he's proud of everything
that now Nanachi has become
and they come to an understanding right
as not achieved this time around refuses to fall
for his sweet honeyed words
and she watches Bondrewd finally kick the bucket.
Meanwhile, a weeping Riko then sees something
fall out of precious cartridges.
It's a white whistle, meaning that as her last
dying wish, Prushka sacrificed her life to become
Riko's white whistle, gaining her and the gang
access to the sixth layer of the abyss.
And miraculously, with their mourning period
lasting less time than it takes to cook a bag
of popcorn, the gang then moves on and prepares
to enter the portal to the sixth layer
and just then they see Bondrewd alive again,
along with a new body this time around.
And like a proud, twisted, sadistic, psychopathic
father, he bids them farewell on their journey.
And they evacuate the fifth layer
and finally enter the sixth layer of the wondrous
and terrifying abyss.
And if you want to join us in the seventh
layer of abyss,
don't forget to like come and subscribe
and check out the How to Be playlist and below.